sam Amick these senior NBA writer for
the athletic joins us let me start with
that question there Sam if you're a
Knicks fan would you rather tune in to
see Kevin Durant or Zion Williamson then
fascinating question I don't know I
think it's a matter of does your brain
work on the business side of the
basketball side I mean Diane's amazing
but we can't forget there is a chance
that he won't pan out you know what I
mean like so I'm gonna go with the
guaranteed commodity and the guy that he
might not feel the seeds to the degree
that LeBron would or somebody like that
but he's gotta fill seeds and you know
what he is and he know that he's got a
lot of years of Paula Fame basketball in
front of them so I'll do Cady do you
think when that lottery happens that
next day that it will affect Kevin
Durant's plans Kyrie Irving's plans
maybe somebody else does the lottery and
we're Zion goes
affects anybody's free agency plans I
think a hundred percent I think one of
the things if we could you know
Watergate style like break into the
front offices of all these different
teams I guarantee it you know they've
got their scenarios in place already for
if Zion goes to you know your team what
the package then looks like that you
where you are then trying to get Anthony
Davis not to say that every team that
might get Zion is is going to try to
send them down the line for ad but some
of them will and then the ripple effect
begins and if you get traction on that
front then you know those are the moving
chess pieces here it's Anthony Davis KD
Kyrie where did it go and you know
because none of those guys want to be on
an island trying to do this thing by
themselves you wrote in the athletic
sources Rockets game one referee raids
routed an extensive warriors research
here what are the what are the Rockets
trying to put in front of the front
office there with the NBA and these
officials and how does that affect the
rest of this series
so they I mean they obviously out of
frustration after Game one but this was
something that goes so much farther back
I mean they decided to kind of pull that
curtain back and share with the world
you know through various means if you
will that that they've been doing a lot
of digging on this run for a long time
and there's a lot of layers to it the
one that is front and center right now
that I wrote about was the 2018 Western
Conference Finals and the reality that
they had gotten their hands on the 48th
minute report for all seven games of
that series every team has the ability
to get game reports for their teams you
you can't see other teams game reports
but you can see the games that you're
involved in so they got that data from
the NBA which is just part of the whole
system and then they went through in
line by line essentially audited it and
and came up with data you know gleaned
from the the league issued information
then the conclusion was that they were
harmed to the tune of 93 points on the
aggregate over seven games six out of
the seven games they had double-digit
deficits when it comes to the way things
should have been called they had the
edge and only game two and it was pretty
small so that you know it's it's just
fascinating from an emotional
psychological standpoint now that we
know that if you go back and you watch
Game one and you see the way they
handled the officiating and the
frustration level that they got to it
makes more sense and it doesn't make it
I know a lot of people can't stand the
way they're handling it but I mean it is
what it is they feel like they got
essentially jog out of a chance for the
title last year and they don't want to
see that happen again do you agree with
their strategy if it works you know what
I mean like this is a mitad Li like I
really put myself out they didn't yeah
they they I mean I just I loved it
admittedly as a media members
storyteller like I'm just I'm leaning
into this contrast between the analytics
driven Rockets who have taken this
formula that people laughed at years ago
and they've taken it so far they've
become such a good team and it but the
the ethos of who they are and how they
went down this path has
and you know a lot of what they do this
is a math equation and going to the
free-throw line I'm going to put a
little agent hat on my buddy Kirk
Goldsberry for ESPN he's got a great
book out called sprawl ball just came
out and he details the fact that the
free throw is just far and away in terms
of points per shot the best odds you
have in this game and so when they are
in Game one of the conference finals I
mean it's better than a wide-open three
it's better than anything else on the
floor it's not even close it's better
than a wide-open Steph Curry 3 as he
writes in his book and that's why
they're losing their minds when the
referees and their eyes are taking that
tool away because it's essentially like
wait a minute this is our script this is
what we do that's why James Harden
you'll see him because listen James
doesn't shoot the 3 like Steph does not
even close so the 3 for him is even even
lower metric but you get him to the line
and it's just it's just you know it's
just cash money so that's why they're
going crazy that they're not going to
the line when they think they should be
but are the Rockets saying that there's
bad officiating or there's preferential
treatment there's there's a bias going
on here because I think there's that's
two separate categories
one is really serious if you're accusing
the NBA of having preferential
treatments or a bias towards Golden
State then you know the Commissioner
needs to have a conversation with
somebody in Houston I would I'd split
the difference there and I would say to
my knowledge I've not had anybody going
complete tinfoil hat approach and saying
the fix is in I think that the feeling
is a couple of hearings for one that the
champs in general you know they step on
the floor they come with a certain
gravitas that I think it seemed like the
Rockets feels like that instantly
changes the kind of the mood in the room
and might impact the officials because
of what they've been able to accomplish
secondly the more specifically and this
is where you know they're not going to
find a lot of allies with this argument
but like the force of personality on the
Warriors individually draymond you know
Kevin the way he's
to become pretty confrontational with
dress even Steph you know what he did in
Minnesota Steve Kerr absolutely the way
that he kind of works official to his
style that they feel like the Warriors
are just master manipulators with the
referees and they're trying to shed
light on that now the part where they
lose people is I mean no you know James
Harden and Chris Paul are at the top of
the list of guys that that that
certainly do their share of complaining
through their share of manipulating and
so it's a little bit of the pot calling
the kettle black there but I think those
two factors are probably what they hone
in on so what happens tonight I don't
think the Rockets are gonna roll over by
any means I think some people feel like
the optics of this whole thing the PR
fallout of the stuff that come out might
lead you know to a blowout I don't see
that happening
I don't know who wins it but I think
we're in for a long series the thing is
it like people can recoil all they want
at the way the Rockets get the job done
but I'm not about to kind of like forget
the degree to which they've gotten the
job done since mid-december they're just
an extremely good basketball team with
an approach that you have to assume
tonight and this is what they were
certainly hoping for that you know a lot
of those 5050 calls probably going to go
their way or at minimum the ones that
you know they had some in the first half
in Game one that we're not 5050 they
were you know hundred percent should
have gone the other way and they didn't
get them so wouldn't shock me at all see
them go steal one at Oracle I mean they
have one is it two times there this year
already you know they're they're not
really afraid of that environment and
the Warriors you know even independent
of all the Warriors locker room drama
stuff that's happened during the season
just basketball wives be their depth is
an issue the Rockets had better depth
and and so I think it'll be a tight
series for sure I don't know if it comes
down to something as simple as this
though Sam and that is you have the
Rockets with new school approach of
basketball and the officials maybe with
an old school of officiating and they're
not sure how to officiate the the
Rockets and in particular James Harden
right right absolutely I mean I just saw
my I hate
in the piece and certainly didn't come
up with that on my own they have a
feeling this is where it gets even more
interesting that older more experienced
officials the Rockettes believe and this
is part of their research that they are
less willing to essentially conform with
the way the NBA has chosen to legislate
you know specifically the landing space
three-pointer you know you got a stay
out of a guy's space give a spot to land
and that's even if it's his momentum is
carrying him away from where he
initially jumped the idea from their
side is that they have seen from a data
perspective that younger officials
appear you know more on board with that
plan war on border that way of calling
plays like that and then so that's where
well and that's where the playoffs
become a challenge for them because
inevitably the playoff referees are
going to be the more experienced like
the the other night I believe the least
experienced ref on the floor had nine
seasons under his belt and somebody from
the league had told me that's probably
the least experienced staff or
officiating crew that they're gonna see
in the entire playoffs so there might be
some younger guys and younger women
throughout the course of the regular
season that if they look at their data
maybe they were getting more of those
calls maybe that was you know in their
favor and now all of a sudden you know
that's off the table
Scott Foster's officiating tonight's
game too by the way and we know what
Chris Paul and the Rockets think of
Scott Foster what's crazy is that I mean
even the idea that you think solely
about the Rockets first of all when it
comes to Scott speaks volumes about like
good degree to which Scott's been in the
news over the course of time like we've
already forgotten that until recently
the Warriors were the team that had
Scott as public enemy number one you
know they've had they've had him as
their least favorite ref for a long time
and so it should in fairness to the
league and I tweeted this earlier you
know again going back to conspiracy
theory stuff that the
tends to come with this time of year
these crews get determined the first
four games of each series are
predetermined so it's basically just a
happenstance type thing that now adds to
the storyline but it was already
determined before Game one but it's it's
going to be a heck of an environment I
anticipate a repeat of what happened the
other night they crack me up the entire
crowd at Oracle is just at the top of
their lungs chanting refs you suck and I
look down and Daryl Morey was standing
amid the chaos and he didn't he didn't
take parts but you you know guarantee it
between his ears he probably was so you
know nobody's been happy so far we'll
see how it goes Sam great stuff as
always thanks for joining us that's Sam
Amick the senior NBA writer for the
athletic he's the one who had this story
about this extensive warriors research
done by the Rockets for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV streamed for free on VR live or
download the Dan Patrick show at